saying no is one of the hardest things
in the world especially for people who
want to serve other people Etc et cetera
if I see someone's calendar I can
usually tell how much money they're
making it's usually because they're
doing like 10 things and it's because
they said yes to too much stuff this
isn't my quote it's Warren Buffett's but
he said the difference between
successful people and extraordinarily
successful people is that
extraordinarily successful people say no
to almost everything easy say no to the
easy ones right the hard no's are the
ones that I had to learn and so I think
when I reframed the nose as actual yeses
to the things that mattered most I
stopped feeling bad about them so it's
like rather than saying no to your
friend you're saying yes to your wife
instead of saying no to your parents
dream you're saying yes to yours it just
felt like I was shutting somebody else
down but I wasn't breathing life to the
alternative